this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thanks Tony appreciate
everyone coming out this afternoon so
I'm gonna be talking about perennial
greens this is a bit of a new area of
research for me so I don't have a whole
lot of data to show you but I'm going to
be telling you what we're up to in my
lab and so I'm I just want to share a
little little nugget of information so
on my on my profile online for the the
section not the department I have a
research description and I say what I'm
interested in and cover crops as Tony
was mentioning sustainable cropping
systems ecological weed management and I
have two words so I say I'm interested
in perennial greens and I received more
comments students enquiries coming in
from outside asking about that those two
words out of a hundred word description
of my research then than anything else
that I do even though I'm not doing a
whole lot of work in this area quite yet
so there's a lot of interest and I hope
you enjoy what what I have to offer here
so I have a lot of slides so I want to
just go through and tell you what the
take-home messages are first in case we
don't get to the end of the presentation
and that is that perennial greens are
becoming an option all right
for the longest time people have just
talked about this is more of a dream
well now it's becoming a reality
so there's increasing interest and
consumer demand people have gotten wind
of what's going on there are people that
are seeking out perennial green products
and there are processors that are very
interested in getting their hands on
this grain so really exciting time to be
working on perennial grains what fits
into my research program and one of the
reasons why I'm very interested in
kernel grains is because they have a
potential to provide ecosystem services
and increase the sustainability of
cropping systems okay when we're
thinking about perennial grains because
this is a new new type of crop the
integration strategy is really important
and critical for success okay so exactly
how we go about growing these crops
where on the landscape they're they're
planted and how they're managed alright
so that that's really important and then
with also being a new crop guidelines we
need we need to understand how these
crops grow and we need some more
information so that we can share this
information with
farmers and provide them with
information on best management practices
in ways to optimize production okay so
before I go any further I just want to
highlight some of the people who are
involved in this research at Cornell and
beyond
saundra Wayman she's really uh so in the
front here she's been really leading the
charge keeping this project together so
very happy to have her involved Valentin
Debray so this is Valentin this is a an
intern from France from esra Lyon who
came over this past summer and helped
with some of the research Eugene law is
a new graduate student right here
working with Toni ditomasso and myself
and then Steve Coleman so this is Steve
you know having its arms up here saying
why aren't people growing more perennial
greens so he was actually from Cornell
yet he's an alum so it came through the
program here at Cornell he's at Ohio
State University now he's really was my
entryway into with working with
perennial green so he's when it really
got me first interested in this work and
then lead to Han he came and actually
gave a seminar in this section a couple
of years ago talking about some of the
updates of his work at the land
institute ok so why why focus on
perennial greens so again thinking about
why I'm really interested in this it's a
lot of it has to do with climate change
if you remember Mike Hoffman's
presentation earlier in the semester
climate change is a really big big deal
for agriculture there are a lot of
challenges associated with climate
change in the future
associated with the projections and I
see perennial grains as a way to deal
with some of those challenges the recent
advances in crop breeding I think are
really exciting and so there's
opportunity for seeing some pretty fast
progress over the next several years
with perennial greens and then ecosystem
services people are starting to
understand the importance of ecosystem
services and the importance of how we
manage our landscapes our agricultural
landscape so that we can achieve not
only food production but also some of
these other environmental benefits that
we get from agro ecosystems okay so with
ecosystem services in 2005 Jonathan Pohl
publish this paper global consequences
of land use and was really calling for
an integration of of what we're seeing
in natural ecosystems where you have a
lot of ecosystem services in this flower
diagram these are represented up here
from forest production and carbon
sequestration number of these on the
bottom of the flower diagram here and
that's quite a bit different from
intensive cropland where the primary
goal is is crop production ok and so
what we're trying to do here is to
combine these two alright so that we get
the best of both worlds and that's what
we're seeing here with this cropland
with restored ecosystem services and
we're seeing perennial greens as an
opportunity to achieve this ok there was
a published not too long ago looking at
the the way that we can put perennials
and this in this case are talking about
perennials in general not necessarily
perennial greens but how we can place
these on the landscape to increase
ecosystem services and what they're
seeing is that with just a small amount
of perennials in the landscape we can
dramatically increase the amount of
ecosystem services that we're we're
receiving from these agro-ecosystem 's
and also achieve green or crop
production at the same time ok so we
think about why why why we're focused on
perennial cropping systems perennial
greens one of the reasons is because
there are challenges with annual
cropping systems and if you think take a
step back and you think about annual
cropping systems and the ecology of
annual cropping systems we know that
these are good in that they are highly
productive so we're getting a lot of
food out of annual cropping systems ok
but they often require very large
amounts of external inputs ok so rich
Smith came and gave a presentation in
the section several years ago and he had
a paper that came out looking at
agriculture energy use environmental
impact and he called into question
annual cropping systems and said that
you know what we're really trying to do
here is maintain this perpetual state of
secondary succession
of initial secondary succession all
right and so we're doing that with
disturbance and we're doing that to
increase resource availability okay so
in ecological terms we're using these
inputs to make resources available for
these plants that we want to grow okay
and the environmental impacts associated
with annual cropping systems is directly
related to the the energy that's
required to maintain that state of
initial secondary succession okay
so some more background information just
here to set the stage if we look at
annual cropping systems alright there's
an example we see that there could be a
lot of evapotranspiration or evaporation
excuse me a lot of runoff okay
especially if you're on a sloped land
like we have a lot of in New York this
is a photograph from 2015 all right at
the musgrave research farm seeing some
railroading here and so in 2015 in june
there was quite a bit of rain so we had
about 8 inches of rain where our
long-term average is about 4 and at the
research farm and for all of you who do
field research who are around this
summer we know that this past summer
2016 it didn't look anything like this
it was actually the complete opposite we
had less than one inch
okay so we're seeing these dramatic
swings in environmental conditions in in
rainfall patterns and you know I think
this is going to continue and we really
need to help farmers deal with some of
these issues ok so going back to this
diagram comparing annual and perennial
cropping systems perennial grains here
so you see these differences so a couple
things that I want to point out so
evaporation decreasing because we're
having more ground cover here ok you
also see a larger nutrient pool that can
be accessed by these roots that go down
deeper with perennial grains compared to
annual grains ok let's run off in
erosion alright and the other thing
that's happening here if you look at the
the diagram of the sons all right here
we're using resources over an extended
period of time with perennial grain
cropping systems all right we're annuals
you're planting and
april/may okay you're missing out on
some of those heat units that happen
before you plant your crop all right and
the same thing after you harvest your
crop in the fall so with perennial
grains you're really taking advantage of
all the resources that are available
throughout the year okay so there are
two main approaches for developing
perennial grains one is to domesticate a
wild crop or a wild perennial excuse me
and the other one is to cross a crop an
annual crop with a penny already two
main approaches for developing perennial
grain crops and what the breeders are
really trying to do is combine multiple
desirable traits so they're looking at
regrowth per any allottee is really
important for perennial grains okay and
high yield so we're trying to get both
of these together into the same plant
all right obviously they should also be
somewhat tolerant abiotic and biotic
stresses so those are the the goals for
the plant breeders and one of the big
success stories is with intermediate
wheat grass all right so this is um
the scientific name is thin opium
intermedium it's also called turns ax
this is the trade name that was
developed by the land Institute so this
is Leda Han is the the plant breeder at
the Land Institute he's been developing
this particular crop so this was first
identified in 1983 by Peggy Wagner down
at the the Rodale Institute they called
it something different down there they
called it wild tree --ga that name is
not stuck where Kearns o has really
taken off okay and this this plant this
was identified out of a screening that
involved over a hundred plants a hundred
different species and they found that
this one was the best in terms of having
these desirable characteristics okay so
this is what the grain looks like
alright it has a hole on it so like oats
so that's a one issue that we've been
dealing with is trying to figure out how
to get this stuff clean and what's
really exciting is that we're now seeing
the first commercial production of this
crop alright so these are some plots and
this is in Kansas looking at combine
harvests of the
the Kern's up and this is what the grain
looks like all right I think this is the
nicest picture of the grain that I've
ever seen our grain you know the brain
that we grew here in New York doesn't
quite look as nice but we're getting
there I'm just going to pass this around
so you can see you know this stuff is
real okay and what's really exciting is
that the first commercial product is now
available so Patagonia the clothing
company outdoor clothing company they
have started a new offshoot company new
branch called Patagonia provisions or
eight that uses the same kind of model
that they used with their clothing
company where the clothing should be
produced sustainably to start looking at
food and so I think the original plan
was that they were going to develop a
granola bar but they went with beer
instead all right and so this is long
route ale I actually have a can of this
stuff so Eugene was was kind enough to
acquire some of this beer which was
quite tasty because when we tried it but
this is really exciting again because
people have always talked about this for
the past twenty thirty years people have
talked about perennial greens but there
was no no commercial production of it
and that we have are now at this point
is just really exciting one thing if you
look at the fine print it says free
ground shipping on orders over $75
unfortunately we can't get it shipped to
New York State the U that doesn't apply
for the beer that's where the other
products that they have okay so and just
in case anybody was interested in
ordering some long route al another
exciting thing happening with Kearns ax
is that there was recently a a proposal
developed and this is the front cover of
this proposal
and this was for General Mills the food
company the folks at the land Institute
have been in contact with General Mills
and they have had requested a proposal
to support research on Kearns ax and
what they're trying to do here is to go
back up the supply
Chane to try to find ways that they can
meet their sustainability objectives
this is very similar to the work that
dr. Van Ness Harrell Dennis is doing
with Walmart and using adapt 10 so
they're going up the supply chain to try
to figure out how to increase the
sustainability of their operation of
their corporation all right and so
General Mills aims to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions by 28 percent by 2025 and
and so in order to achieve that goal
they're looking to utilize 18 million
pounds of turns ax annually by 2025 ok
so this proposal was developed and what
they're calling for here is the
development of the Kearns Development
Consortium all right and I really like
this last part here that's funded by an
aggressive an aggressive investment in
research over the next 15 years so I am
on this this I'm part of this Kearns of
development consortium I'm really
excited to see this moving forward
hopefully we'll be doing a lot more
research on terms of in the near future
with help from General Mills so again
the ecosystem services that we're
talking about with perennial grains
we're talking about providing both food
and and potentially forage it's not
listed there but carbon sequestration
habitat for wildlife and when we're
growing these crops as opposed to annual
crops we can reduce tillage reduce our
soil erosion and reduce pollution from
the inputs that we're using to grow
these crops so I wanted to highlight
some of the past work by Steve Coleman
so this these plots are out at KBS this
was back a number of years ago I think
in 2012
maybe 2011 but Steve invited me out to
kbs2 as for part of this perennial
grains meeting and we got the tour some
of his plots and what they found in this
research was that currency yields were
quite low oh great currency is the
perennial plant in the back this is
annual wheat in the middle here and then
this is perennial wheat so the perennial
wheat here this is the cross this is
crossing the the annual crop with the
perennial relative all right
turns on you know on the other hand is
the
domesticated wild wild perennial okay
and so they saw that the yields were
quite low all right with Kearns ax
especially in the first year they
planted a bit late all right
so an establishment year very low but
they got up to about a third of annual
wheat in the second year all right they
also found that currents of reduced
nitrogen losses and and also had lower
moisture deeper in the soil profile
there are not a summary results for
perennial wheat because the perennial
wheat did not fare so well although the
grain yields were higher in the first
geo year all right it was not it did not
persist
all right so died off so the Pernis
allottee all right is a really big issue
here with this one good yields but the
it did not survive okay so when we look
at some of these data we're looking at
soil moisture alright in the profile so
this is 0 to 20 centimetres 20 to 40 40
to 70 and 70 to 100 all right and what
you're seeing here is that the perennial
the perennial grain and this is in case
currants are compared to annual wheat
all right so it's drying out the the
soil more so it's utilizing soil
moisture to a greater degree than the
annual annual wheat certainly in the
year one over here 2010 and then in 2011
it's more pronounced in the as you go
deeper in the soil profile okay so that
was so moist year here we're looking at
at nitrate leaching alright so they
installed my scimitar Zinn these plots
and they were looking at three different
types of nitrogen source so high
nitrogen a middle rate of 80 pounds of
nitrogen per acre as urea and then an
organic source of nitrogen so another 80
pounds as poultry litter and what
they're seeing here again the perennial
Grande turns a is the blue line alright
and you're seeing virtually no leaching
alright so that current so those deep
roots alright you can see here they're
really sucking up that that nitrogen
that nitrate and preventing it from
leaching out so that's what we're
talking about reducing pollution
associated with with these inputs that
we're using to grow our crops there's
also a lot of interest
in using perennial crops like Kern's ax
to increase soil carbon sequestration
and as a tool for climate change
mitigation in our lab I've been working
on a review paper for the past year more
than a year I think but we're looking at
different cropping systems you know
specific cropping strategies for working
with perennial green crops one of those
is using perennial rye which I'll talk
about in a second all right very similar
to perennial wheat where it's a cross
between the annual crop and the
perennial relative intermediate wheat
grass combined with a perennial Legum
forage and then and then this one here
this highly diverse perennial grain
polyculture and so if we just start with
that one this is really what Wes Jackson
was thinking when he does a lot of his
talks about perennial grains and this is
a with this strategy we're really trying
to mimic nature having all of these
different species growing together so
this is supposed to simulate what we're
seeing in the prairies where you have
different species and they self-regulate
and you can imagine that you can have a
quite a bit of ecosystem services coming
from a situation like this and so we are
not actively working on developing this
type of system mainly because of the
complexity associated with it if we look
at this this graphic here just this
example alright if we look at the number
of crop species that we're including in
a mixture or in a polyculture you can
imagine that the ecosystem services if
you follow this line here they increase
with the number of crop species that you
have alright and then you hit an
asymptote but the management complexity
also increases and and we're not exactly
sure what these this relationship looks
like in terms of management complexity
it could be a lot different than that
the shape of the curve that I just drew
but we know it increases what we're
thinking about is how can we do this how
can we be smart about putting these
species together so that we can increase
our ecosystem services actually achieve
a higher level of ecosystem services all
right so we're here we're getting up
nine all right we're over here we're
only getting up to seven and then also
change change and make sure that we're
being strategic about our species that
were including so that the management
complexity is also reduced all right so
if you are strategic about it we think
that there is potential here but again
the the main concern here is with this
management complexity and just being
able to grow these crops together in a
meaningful way
what does seem like we can get some
traction with is with perennial rye
we're looking at this crop as part of a
at least thinking about it as part of a
rotation where we would have it in in a
rotation with annual crops where we can
increase the soil soil health over
several years and then rotate back to
annual crops to take advantage of that
increased soil health so again I already
talked a little bit about this being
across these these yields have been a
bit higher than then-current own at
least in the past with previous research
but there is some problems and so with
the title of the the presentation the
the promises the problems and the
progress I really want you to focus on
the progress of course but there are
some problems that we need to
acknowledge this is one of the problems
with our gate or gate is a fungal
disease and it can be pretty pretty bad
in terms of the impact health impacts
it's causes a create psychoactive
compounds so that's something that we
really want to avoid when I first
started thinking about perennial rye I
thought we could use this for distilling
to support the distilling industry
around here but it turns out that forget
the alkaloids will actually go through
the distilling process and so that
really isn't going to be a viable way to
deal with it so we're looking at color
separation for dealing with any organs
that we have with perennial rye so this
this option this of including
intermediate wheatgrass with the
perennial forage this does seem like one
of the most tractable ways to move
forward there's been a lot of progress
with this we're interested in combining
these two different types of crops
because of the ability of the legume to
supply nitrogen to the
and and also increase the Ford's quality
if we're thinking about dual purpose use
of turns off harvesting in both for
grain and for forage having a legging
forage in there would certainly be nice
so when you are intercropping one of the
challenges especially when you're
dealing with perennials is the managing
competition so depending on the time of
establishment if you're planting them at
the same time or if you're trying to put
in the legging later you can have one
species easily out-compete the other and
so we're taking an active look at that
we have a new experiment that Eugene
Eugene law will be helping with managing
in the future this was just established
this past summer and so this is
comparing two annual grains to two
perennial greens and and all of them
have this split split plot with with red
clover so with and without red clover
and so this will be a three-year
experiment where the annuals are are
repeatedly planted so kind of a worst
case scenario to really look at what
happens if you do something that you're
not supposed to do but comparing that to
these perennial grains here okay so our
hypotheses are that soil health and soil
health will be greater and pests will be
lower in plots with perennial grains
compared to plots with annual grains and
that red clover will increase grain
yields and overall profitability okay so
in terms of our measurements we're
looking at crops crop performance
indicators biomass grain yield and also
pests grain quality soil health
indicators and soil erosion that's
another factor that we're really
interested in this is what the plots the
plants look like 28 days after planting
so turns ax over here and then the
perennial rye all right these
photographs aren't the best but this is
55 days after planting and you can see
the differences here so the kearns of
plots all right there is some green in
there it looks like a lot of soil right
now about being a perennial this crop is
just much much slower than the
annuals over here okay we came up with
these varieties by working with some
local farmers that we're collaborating
with and so these are popular varieties
with them and so hopefully they'll be
interested in our results and then this
is what the perennial ride looks like a
little bit better than the Kern zone but
not quite as good as those annual annual
small grains so that was a new
experiment I'm going to tell you about
an experiment that we have been working
on over the past two years and
established it was established in 2014
and this is with Steve Coleman this
dual-purpose Kern's experiment and this
is really one of the reasons why we're
interested in in conducting the
experiment with Eugene looking at
combining the red clover with the
currants off and that is because we're
thinking that ferns a-- can be used for
not only grain but also for forage
production and so the grain yields have
traditionally been very low okay we see
that the grain yields typically peak at
years one and two all right and then
they decline they decline because of the
plant being sod bound okay so it's a
this planet is highly prized amitis and
then it forms a sod and this sod that
limits really the the reproductive
tiller tillering density and and could
be very problematic in terms of
maintaining grain yield alright steve
has done some work looking at fertilizer
applications and so currency does
respond to nitrogen but like many small
grains if you apply too much it can fall
over and result in logic so that's one
of those issues and there are goals in
the objective you know the questions
that we're asking is can we offset the
low grain production with added value of
forage alright and so we're trying to
look at both green and forge yields over
a range of different environments and
then how can we mitigate the declining
grain yields over time and so what is
the effect of defoliation on grain
yields okay so these slides or some of
this information was recently presented
at the try society meeting and so these
are the different locations where this
research is being conducted so we're
your number number five here at Cornell
but you can see we're all over all over
the US so Colorado Kansas Maryland
Minnesota New York Ohio Iowa Wisconsin
South Dakota and even in Canada okay I
just wanted to make a note that there
are 30 percent of the people here are
from Cornell they've come through
Cornell program so there's certainly a
Cornell connection with these different
researchers I think that's perpetuated
by Steve Coleman just knowing these
folks but interesting nonetheless and so
with these different treatments in this
experiment there are four different
treatments there's a control this green
treatment where we're just harvesting
the grain there's a forage and grain and
then a fall cut okay as we go through
this I really just want you to pay
attention to these two the grain and
then the forage and grain so this is
standard basically the standard practice
all right and then this is trying to get
some forage from these plots in the
spring and then harvesting for grain
okay we also had some nitrogen
treatments using urea applying at two
different rates
all right using a split application and
so I have some photographs for you so
this is the spring growth this is in
2015 so it was planted and in August of
2014 so this is over wintered in May
this is harvesting with the very old
Carter harvest area so this is Brian
Caldwell
one of the folks that's in my lab
harvesting on May 22nd you can see what
the plots look like after they were
harvested all right cut to a height of
four inches one of the problems that we
that we had with starting off this
experiment was that we went into a field
that had previously been planted to
annual wheat and so I was thinking that
this was a good idea the field was open
no big deal and it turns out that there
was a lot of a lot of contamination a
lot of the annual wheat
Daten wasn't collected in the combining
process it was distributed across the
field and so there were a lot of annual
wheat heads mixed in with the Kern's uh
at least during the first year okay and
for were the research plots we had a
quite an amazing crew of undergraduates
undergraduate research assistants who
went out and and hand-picked a lot of
the the annual wheat heads and I I think
they they almost killed me for that but
uh but it helped clean things up quite a
bit this is a picture of our pot combine
going through the research pot another
challenge that we had with with this
crop was harvesting it was direct
combining with the with the research
plot combine we did have a lot of
clogging a lot of the material wasn't
completely dry the thing is with
perennial grains so they're drawing from
the top down right an annual grain will
dry from the bottom up okay and so we
need to dry you know you don't have to
deal with wet material you can go
through with your combine you have the
cutter bar it cuts everything passes
through the combine without any problems
here the lower you go the greener it
gets okay and so that was a bit of an
issue for us and so I think we learned a
lot over the past couple of years this
was using the the farm combine that has
an air rail up in front and this was a
lot easier to use just have a greater
capacity to get the material through the
combine it was fairly dirty our first
harvest we had a lot of a lot of extra
material in there we had a lot of annual
wheat despite the hand weeding and so we
weren't all that all that thrilled about
our first harvest but it's certainly
exciting to see and here are some of the
the plots that had nitrogen applied to
them you can see the extra green I was
and you see here this is where the urea
was applied and we didn't have a whole
lot of
impacts on the on the grain we did see
greater forage biomass production from
the nitrogen at least in the fall but no
effect on the grain yield here the plots
post an thesis in July this past year in
2016
ok and now I'm going to show you grain
yields across all nine sites so these
are just box plots going from Colorado
all the way on left to Wisconsin here in
the two years ok so average across all
the sites grain yields were a bit higher
in 2015 compared to 2016 but overall
very low ok and so I encourage you not
to think about this in comparison to
annual grains because that'll just maybe
be a little depressing but but this is
exciting we are getting grain off of
these perennial plants ok and I think
that's the main takeaway point here ok
it's a low yield but it's something ok
so if we're looking at just New York
alright so here are the two treatments
that I ask you to pay attention to in
the two different years alright and so
we're looking at basically the the
biomass alright so this is the straw
okay this is the the forage at the time
of grain harvest okay
these plots over here they had this
spring cut so this is where we went in
when it was still very green and we
harvested these plots for forage ok and
then we went back and we harvested them
for grain and then this is the straw
yield associated with that grain harvest
okay so no no real difference overall in
terms of overall biomass production but
this alright this is quite a bit
different material than this here ok
when we look at the forage quality of
the spring cut so the green material
compared to the summer cut we see that
there are some pretty big differences
this is just some an example of what
we're shooting for with our forage
quality metrics here so crude protein in
this case it was higher associated with
the with the straw okay if you think
about it there's probably some grain
that's going into this
and that's driving up that that that
straw protein value at the summer cut
okay but everything else okay so if we
look at the relative feed value okay so
a good relative feed value is above 150
so we're up to a 214 with that early cut
okay and so we're really excited about
these results we see that that Kearns a
can make some very nice forage and the
next question is well does that forage
clip really impact the grain yield okay
and so although not statistically
different our first year we did see that
the the forage harvest didn't we did see
a numerically lower yield than just
harvesting the grain alone
okay but overall it wasn't all that
consistent here we did see that same
negative effect when we take the forage
we did have a lower grain yield but in
the other cases again no no impact okay
and these are not all the same set years
some of the other sites did not did not
have this exact treatment or did not
manage it the same way so just as this
is a just a reduced set of those
different sites so in terms of the dual
purpose current experiment so yields
varied widely we saw that in terms of
the control treatment we didn't talk a
lot about the control treatment but
that's basically just harvesting the
green versus going in and taking out the
straw when we take out the straw we see
some higher yields alright and so what I
think is actually happening there is
when you mow those pots after you
harvest you're actually getting some
weed control associated with that we did
have some perennial weeds that crept
into the pot and so reducing that
biomass that's standing biomass was
beneficial alright
spring clipping reduced plant height and
so in terms of the lodging problem we
think that that can help especially if
we are going to be adding nitrogen to
try to increase our crop yields and so
so we're really excited about this
experiment it's continuing I want to
shift gears a little bit and tell you
about some other research that we've
done in the lab we conducted a survey of
farmers so we wanted to really know
what's going on with farmers have they
heard about perennial
Graeme's before are they interested in
potentially growing perennial brains and
so this was a survey of farmers and also
processors we're still working on
analyzing the processor data set but we
want to gauge interest and this was
conducted in France and in the u.s. so
we have some collaborators christophe
david at is there a lyon and this was
Valentin's project over the summer ok so
we had a fairly decent response rate so
over four hundred farmers responded to
this survey so a lot more in France I
think we could have probably done a
better job getting the word out in the
US but we had a decent response rate or
a decent response anyway we used
snowball sampling so we can't actually
calculate a response rate because we
don't know how many people saw the
survey link but we were happy to get
this many people responding and so I
want to show you a couple of the results
from this this survey here we're looking
at motivations for growing perennial
grains okay and so the number one
motivation and we have it broken out by
organic and conventional farmers so we
looked at the demographics of the the
pool of respondents and we saw that
there was a nice split between organic
and conventional and that was somewhat
intentional we wanted to have a lot of
organic farmers so we see that this this
first one here increasing our
maintaining farm profitability so that's
the number one reason why farmers would
be interested in growing perennial
grains and that sort of makes sense this
was significantly different more
conventional farmers and organic farmers
we're interested in that that factor
reducing inputs ok so conventional
farmers again want to try to reduce
their inputs using this perennial grain
compared to an annual grain reducing
labor so this is where the organic
farmers you know we're more interested
in reducing labor than the conventional
farmers ok the other thing that we see
here diversifying crop production again
a big difference between the organic and
conventional farmers with the organic
farmers thinking that perennial greens
can help them diversify ok forage
alright more of the organic farmers that
we surveyed grew forage crops and had
livestock so this made sense to us that
more the organic farmers would be
interested in using perennial greens for
that dual purpose of both grain
and forge we also asked about concerns
so potential reasons why they might not
grow perennial grains and so what we see
here is increased pest problems
so more organic farmers and conventional
farmers both types of farmers we're
interested in or concerned about the low
grain yield high seed costs and and this
lack of market where you can sell your
crop conventional farmers were more
concerned about low profitability okay I
thought this was interesting that you
know in terms of low grain yield and low
profitability
you know the organic farmers they
weren't as concerned about low
profitability than as the conventional
farmers so I think we'll just stop there
with that survey graph we also had some
targeted questions okay
so there's some very specific questions
that we want to get them to respond to
and they were asked to agree or disagree
with the statement so the first one is
I'm interested in dual dual purpose
perennial greens perennial crops that
can be harvested for both green and
forage so more organic farmers agreed
with that statement than conventional
farmers so 148 compared to only 36 and
if you look at the percentage so about
70% compared to about 50% okay so this
this next statement I would grow
perennial grains to provide
environmental benefits even if they were
not as profitable as other crops
okay so again organic farmers tended to
agree with that much more than
conventional farmers okay the last one
here is research funding should be spent
on annual grain crops rather than
developing new perennial green crops
okay and I was pleased to see that there
was a lot of disagreement with with that
statement so again there was a
difference between organic and
conventional farmers here more of the
organic farmers disagreed with that
statement compared to the conventional
farmers okay so we do see farmer
interest in perennial greens and and
there's a lot more that can be done with
that survey
this is being worked up right now and
should be submitted to a journal very
soon I also wanted to tell you about a
new grant and from northeast sare titled
developing perennial green cropping
systems and market opportunities in the
Northeast we have quite an ambitious
performance target with with this grant
proposal we said that 20 farmers will
establish perennial greens on a total of
400 acres ok reducing erosion and we
wanted to contribute to the sale of 150
tons of perennial greens all right in
the Northeast so you know looking back
at this I feel a little a little crazy
for thinking that we could do this but
I'm optimistic and the reason why I'm
optimistic is because of our of our team
ok we have an outstanding group of
organic farmers working on this project
and an outstanding project manager
Sondra Wayman alright and these people
are very committed to seeing this work
so we have some on-farm trials we have a
new experiment that musgrave the one I
was telling you about with Eugene and so
we're going to be doing workshops we
have some tasting and a tasting event
that's lined up and then with bakers and
brewers and distillers and also a farm
on farm field day so these are our
farmers that are involved in this
project looking at the plots over the
summer and so what we're going to be
doing is looking at turns ax and then
perennial rye all right these crops were
planted this past September and each of
the different farmers are taking on a
different research question
so tour Austin area is looking at
different ways to harvest the material
the the grain John Mayer is looking at
spring fertility fertilizer rates and
then clost martins is looking at seeding
rates and so these questions were really
farmer generated which is really nice I
think they'll be more excited about the
results and then if we were just to
impose what we wanted to do on onto
their land and so this is Taurasi nur we
planted at his place on September 9 we
were very interested in working with tor
for a number of reasons but one of those
reasons was that in June of 2015 he
incredible rain event at his at his farm
and so this was the wet year all right
he had five inches of rain in one hour
and washed away a lot of his soil so
he's an organic farmer and uses a lot of
tillage so he's really interested in
ways to reduce tillage and we're hopeful
that we can integrate perennial grains
into his his operation in a way to help
him deal with some of that soil erosion
that he's experienced in the past he
stated in his letter of support that
West Jackson some of his writings
actually inspired him to transition from
conventional production to organic
production so that was really exciting
to see he has experienced harvesting
different crops you somewhat unique or
alternative crops for seeds so he
harvest buckwheat you know buckwheat is
a crop that he swapped so he cuts it and
then picks it up off the ground and puts
it through a combine and also red clover
for seed so he is also a part owner of a
flour mill and a bakery so we again he's
vertically integrated and we think that
there could be a lot of opportunities to
work with tor to see this market be
developed so these are the plants one
month after planting the Kern's ax looks
really weedy unfortunately but the
perennial rye looks it looks good all
right here's John Mayer so his plot his
plots were planted on September 15th
he's been a longtime collaborator with
Cornell so John Mayer really pays
attention we did some research with him
this past past summer and we did some
soil testing and some weed seed bank
sampling and we gave him some results
and and he called us out on an issue
that we had he said you know that
doesn't look right and we went back and
we checked in and he was right and so
he's really engaged and he does pay
attention so excellent farmer he is also
the owner of a distillery all right
right along kuegel Lake on the knee on
the west side and so we're thinking that
we could work with him to really try
using some of these perennial greens for
distilling okay
these are what his our pots looked like
41 days after planting the perennial rye
looking a little bit better than the
current saw at this early stage and then
kloss Martin's so a lot of people know
class Martin's a
food company seed and food company
Lakeview organic grains and again a long
history of collaboration with with
Cornell University excellent farmer so
these are pictures of his plots
thirty-five days after planting both the
Kern zone and the perennial rye and so
just to give you a sense for what the
farmers are thinking at this point
getting into this project here are some
early thoughts some feedback they they
pass along to Sandra Wayman so tour he
says he's excited about Kern's uh he
heard about it years ago but skeptical
of the pathetic looking curds of plants
coming up so tours uh if you don't know
tour he he doesn't pull any punches he's
a fun guy and you know I think he's
joking around a little bit there but you
know he's interested to see how it does
on his somewhat poor soil okay John
Mayer he's a bit more he's quiet and he
says uh it's curious so far he hasn't
had a lot of feedback to share with us
yet okay
cloths Martin's on the other hand he's a
very outspoken he is very concerned
about the small seed size with Kearns ax
he has lots of ideas and whenever we go
and visit with cost Martin's he has a
number of different research ideas that
he wants us to start working on so
that's always great it has ideas for the
breeders so he compares it to Emmer and
thinks that forage is going to be
critical for making this work so we're
getting close to the end here just some
I just want to highlight you know we've
talked a lot about the benefits I really
want people to understand that that
there are also some drawbacks we are
moving forward with this but we are very
well aware of some of the issues so in
true holiday spirit with the red and
green I have you know the drawbacks
listed here so that perennial grains are
not going to address these food security
needs and issues that we often talk
about certainly lower yields than our
annual counterparts quality you know
again one of the reasons why we're
working with tor is because he's very in
tune with grain quality he has quality
thresholds that he needs them to meet
for with his green and and so we are
going to be working with him to try to
figure out
we're Kearns ax and printer I fit in
what can be done with them in terms of
processing there is potential for your
pests to build up you know crop rotation
in annual cropping systems all right
that is probably the best way best
cultural practice for managing pests and
so if we're not doing that in perennial
grain cropping systems you know there's
potential for these pests to build up
depending on where you're at if you're
using aquifers to an irrigation
perennial grains might be an issue
because of the water use okay in the
Northeast we don't really see this being
a big problem a lot of times we have
more water than what we need but
depending on where you're at in the West
that can be an issue so covered a lot
just to reiterate the take-home messages
so perennial greens are becoming an
option there's an increasing interest we
see ecosystem services the integration
strategy again the if you are using
polycultures you know the putting the
the complementary species together you
know it's going to be important where
you put it on the landscape okay instead
of taking your your prime AG land that
you're growing annual green crops in
perhaps putting them in sloped land or
using contour strips you know there may
be ways that we can integrate print no
greens in a very meaningful way without
getting ourselves into too much trouble
in terms of having these low yields and
decreasing profitability
so for agronomists in the room so we
really need more people working on on
perennial grains we need to come up with
best management practices and be able to
provide farmers with information that
they need to optimize production so just
like to say thanks for people who have
contributed to this project people have
contributed seed helped out with the
field work and also there are several
people on here that are working on the
review paper with me so thank you very
much I'd be happy to take any questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu